عبد الرحمن البالغ من العمر 12 عامًا لا يستطيع النوم
ليلاً، تقول شقيقته ربيعة إنه
خائف جدًا من البقاء بمفرده، تعرض منزله في
قرية كراه جنوب نابلس
لهجوم من قبل المستوطنين اليهود، يمكنك رؤيتهم
هنا في هذا الفيديو وهم يلقون
الحجارة  إطلاق النار على العقار، مما أدى إلى
تحطيم النوافذ داخل الأرضية، وتناثر
الزجاج الناتج عن الرصاص،
وكشط الجدران، وفراغ قاتم.
قُتل أربعة فلسطينيين محليين
في هذا الهجوم وهم في طريقهم إلى
جنازتهم في اليوم التالي، كما أطلق اثنان
آخران من السكان المحليين إبراهيم وابنه عميد وديع النار
الصور الميتة للجص المفقود على
الجدران في KRA هاني أو دي هو رئيس البلدية هنا
يعيش مجتمعه في خوف، كما يقول، حيث يتعرض
لهجوم مستمر من قبل المستوطنين اليهود
ويقول إن
الوضع يزداد سوءًا، فالوضع سيء للغاية لدرجة أنك
لا تستطيع حتى وصفه، نحن  نعيش في
حالة نفسية مدمرة، لا
يستطيع أحد منا النوم، سيارات مشتعلة، مضخات مياه،
خطوط كهرباء،
نهب، يخبرني هاني أن المستوطنين يتجولون
بحرية هنا في كثير من الأحيان تحت حماية
الشرطة الإسرائيلية، وهدفهم
يصر على طرد الفلسطينيين من
منازلهم وفي نهاية المطاف من
الضفة الغربية المحتلة.  في الحكومة الإسرائيلية الحالية،
وزير الأمن القومي اليميني المتطرف إيتار
بيناف، وهو زعيم استيطاني سابق
أدين سابقًا بدعم
الإرهاب والتحريض على العنصرية ضد العرب،
وآخرون ينكرون
وجود الفلسطينيين بينما كنا نتحدث أنا وأنت، لقد
تلقيت للتو
تحديثًا عاجلاً على هاتفي  هنا مصادر محلية
مستوطنون يقتحمون جبل علامة في بلدة
بيتا المحمية من قبل
قوات الاحتلال السياسة واضحة ليس
سرا أنهم يريدون تهجير هذه المنطقة
علينا فقط الدفاع عن أنفسنا
والدفاع عن أرضنا سنموت هنا أين
سنذهب  على بعد مسافة قصيرة بالسيارة وعلى
مرأى ومسمع من
مستوطنة زاحفة التقينا بإبراهيم وزوجات
عائلة أحمد وبنات وأخوات
حزن على خسارتهم ولكنهم رواقون وفخورون
وزوجي أحب أرضه
ودافع عن أرضه وسنواصل
القيام بذلك طالما نحن كذلك  حيا
أخبرني عن
أحمد أحمد كان مثل والده بطلا
رجلا شجاعا ذو
قلب قوي طالما أن هناك شخص مثل
بيناف يدعمك ويشجعك على
القيام بالعنف بالطبع سيزداد
في ظل تلك
الحياة العنيفة  يستمر الترهيب بالنسبة للبعض مثل
هؤلاء النساء مما يجعلهم
أكثر عزمًا على البقاء ولكن بالنسبة لآخرين
مثل ربيعة وعبد الرحمن الصغير هذه
المرة، أشعر بالسوء الشديد وأريد
البكاء ولكن ما يمكننا فعله هو أنهم انتقلوا إلى
KRA منذ ست سنوات هربًا من الاستقرار
العنف الذي أودى
بحياة والدهم يتم طردهم الآن من منزلهم
مرة أخرى وتحدثنا إلى جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي
وسألناهم عما يفعلونه
لتعزيز أصولهم على
الأرض لدعم الفلسطينيين
لأن هذا  ما الذي من المفترض أن
يفعلوه، كما تعلم أنه من المفترض أن يكونوا هناك
لدعم السكان في
الضفة الغربية المحتلة وقالوا
إنهم معززون بالكامل،
أعني أنهم حصلوا على ما
يحتاجون إليه  هناك